we must use this moment to bring this
crime further out of the Shadows provide
proper support to all victims and
survivors and deliver real and enduring
change
this government has repeatedly shown its
determination to stop the scourge of
child sexual abuse just last month the
Prime Minister and I announced new
measures to tackle the evil of grooming
gangs
but there is zero room for complacency
and the inquiry's final report confronts
us with a necessary moment for further
reflection
it is more than a collection of
recommendations
it is a call for fundamental change
cultural change societal change
professional and institutional change
Madame Deputy speaker I am pleased to
say that this government has risen to
the inquiries challenge
we are accepting the need to act on 19
out of the inquiry's 20 final
recommendations this includes driving
work across government to improve the
victim's experience of the Criminal
Justice System the criminal injuries
compensation scheme Workforce regulation
access to records consistent and
compatible data and Communications on
the scale and nature of child sexual
abuse
we need to stop perpetrators in their
tracks and better protect and support
the children they seek to Prey Upon to
do this we must address a systemic
under-reporting of child sexual abuse
as I announced in April the government
accepts the inquiry's recommendation to
introduce a new mandatory reporting Duty
across England and today I'm launching
the call for evidence which will inform
how this new Duty can be best designed
to prevent the continued abuse of
children and ensure they get help as
soon as possible
the inquiry recommended a redress scheme
for victims and survivors of historic
child sexual abuse which the government
also accepts
of course nobody can ever fully
compensate victims and survivors for the
abuse they suffered but what we can do
is properly acknowledge their suffering
deliver Justice and an appropriate form
of redress
this is a landmark commitment
it will be complex and it will be
challenging
but it really matters
as the inquiry recommends we will
carefully consult victims and survivors
we will draw on lessons from other
jurisdictions and we will make sure that
we honor the inquiry's Legacy as we
Design This scheme
now we accept there is more we can do to
ensure those who have suffered get
access to the provision they need to
help them recover and rebuild their
lives
we have already introduced the victims
and prisoners bill which will ensure the
criminal justice system delivers on
victims entitlements
it will also introduce a new statutory
Duty on local Partners to work together
when commissioning support services for
victims of sexual violence
but there but where we need to go
further we will
we will elicit views on the future of
therapeutic support including systemic
changes to provision through the
extensive consultation we are
undertaking on redress
it is right that we consider these
things together so that we can better
deliver the support needed by child and
adult victims and supporters survivors
of abuse